desde que comenzó la crisis en Rusia y
las tropas Wagner comenzaron a avanzar
hacia Moscú se ha especulado mucho sobre
la ventaja que tomarían las fuerzas
ucranianas a lo largo de esos más de mil
kilómetros de línea de batalla donde
actualmente libran esa contraofensiva
para retomar el control de las
poblaciones que ha tomado Rusia sin
embargo hoy habló la viceministra de
defensa y dijo que hasta el momento en
las tres semanas de contraofensiva
Ucrania ha tomado 130 kilómetros
cuadrados 17 kilómetros cuadrados en las
últimas semanas sigue siendo un avance
lento ellos habían advertido que esto no
puede seguirse como una película de
Hollywood que la defensa rusa al otro
lado es bastante potente especialmente
en el área desaporilla donde tienen tres
líneas de defensa y aseguran que siguen
avanzando y hablaban de una población al
sur de la población de bucle dar en la
provincia de dones que no es muy grande
pero si es estratégica para demostrar
que siguen avanzando en esa provincia de
dones cerca a la ciudad de dones la
capital de esta provincia en control de
las fuerzas separatistas rusas y también
del gobierno de Moscú No desde el 2022
sino desde el 2014 y también siguen los
avances en pacmut esto sí en las últimas
horas una de las brigadas más
importantes allí desplegada la brigada 3
ha dicho que logró retomar un kilómetro
cuadrado en las últimas horas lo que es
un gran Avance en esta zona sin embargo
dicen que la respuesta de las tropas
rusas allí fue feroz que es como si
ellos no supieran realmente lo que está
pasando en su país y así se replican
estas ofensivas a lo largo de esta
frontera no solamente en las cercanías
de bacmut sino también a lo largo de esa
frontera de esa polilla